Captain America's powers comes from him
being a 99 year old virgin that's a real
theory online and I didn't know if
anybody had anything to add to that does
that make any sense to you that's a real
theory that Avengers fans have that he's
99 is he a virgin he's a virgin holding
up yeah all in the why the why yeah
that's beautiful yeah because if he
doesn't want to go there because he's
trying to harness that strength for you
know saving the universe then it makes
sense it's a beautifully that's a
beautiful thought that theory was
definitely written by a virgin I know
that I derived a great deal of power
once from being a 46 year old and that
the loss of that power has been a great
regret yeah so I just thought Anthony is
right because when you when you think
intimidating do you think virgin right
what do you think terrifyingly powerful
do you think virgins Oh son of Godzilla
baby Zilla that's the question I was
getting to Mothra what kind of mom
saying these questions will go away if
we can just keep this this flow going of
more women yeah just just pure garbage
coming from other guys and I'm really
surreal coming here you gave a really
thoughtful answer about your apt in
America and then Anthony you just took
us just wanted to know what website you
was on yeah you want a lot of websites
mmm let's not get into all that
look in your cookies no no maybe it's
like Buddhist monk would you say babies
a Buddhist monk besides all the killing
in the the war it's like holding out for
something else to get any more questions
you